I'll just give you a heads up around a
bit of a time crunch we only have a 35
minutes of battery which for us is now a
lot of time oh yeah but uh I'm sure we
can talk about this fine he doesn't know
we were talking about Rob let's do a
real thoughts on video we put back up
recently as been taken down and put back
up taking down put back up let's talk
about which church the purge works yes
it just works
um a little history about this movie I
saw the trailer says the dumbest thing
I've ever see in my life my wife really
wanted to see it on Valentine's Day uh
so that's how you know you married the
right woman I I guess he I was either
that or some rom-com okay yeah no I'll
I'll give it that
but it at the same time it's like I like
a Valentine's Days turn to like slaw
it's like the Valentine's Day Massacre
day I think they get like it wrong with
the movies because that Deadpool comes
out of L times day anyway so I see this
movie and we both have a pretty good
laugh we thought was very very funny
even though it wasn't supposed to be
funny
and it was just something where
afterwards I just couldn't stop talking
about a good shut up about it was just
made me laugh how ridiculous it was and
I said you know we gotta do a review on
this and recently I've kind of tried to
do films in some way tied into nostalgia
I'm gonna do something recent so I
probably wouldn't do something like the
purge nowadays but it was just so
friggin stupid but also so amazing
nostalgic for better horror movie baby
is is it you know I haven't talked about
it and you didn't see it until I said
we're doing a review of it like we're
just we're doing it cuz I also thought
the guy was a lot like Matthew and I'm
just like we cuz Matthew looks so much
like this guy that's all I could think
of and nobody else was drawing that
comparison and of course Matthew did
that unbelievable jammed in the review
and now that same dude he was the best
thing in the movie his name is not Henry
by the way at sech and they have the
boyfriend but since he didn't have a
name I decided that's just as good a
name as any so I just assumed there's
two Henry's in the movie because people
remember that character much more than
the boyfriend who just out of nowhere
came in and whatever
trying to shoot that dad or some dumb
shit so pilots um but anyway yeah uh he
was it he was in what the hell was it I
was watching he was in something it was
dry Oh arrow he shows up he shows up an
arrow as this like minor role and then
our no minor roles when it comes to him
it yeah it was one of those things words
like it he definitely was more
restrained but I'm like now he better
end up being a bad guy because I cannot
take him seriously as like somebody
who's supposed to be a quote-unquote
good guy um
and sure enough and he was great but
that one drove me nuts oh because I did
I didn't recognize him the first episode
but in the second episode I'm like is
that the dude from the purge like no
like it couldn't be I'm like maybe and
then like they seriously I swear to God
were just like what yak like it's the
purge or something and then like he
crashed his smile and I'm like oh my god
they did you did it arrow that guy is
like the one guy who's just having like
the time of his life
way too much yeah uh you know everyone
else is like trying to take it seriously
I'm sure like maybe in his head he kind
of felt like or made the drug I don't
know I jump to conclusions but he acts
like you know in his head he's thinking
like this is gonna be like the chilling
Oscar contender you know to go up there
or something like that and is just so
over the top and so crazy but so
passionate it's just so under taining ly
fun I my room and I was I was reading an
interview nothing's the director of the
writer but with somebody one of the main
creators involved and they were saying
like they base it on the idea that
everybody gets one like wouldn't be nice
we could just kill one person it was
like the directors wife yeah would it be
nice if everybody who's got one day
where you know they could do it or
something like that I think she meant it
as a comedy hey there are a comedy or
just an idea the problem I have with it
is it takes itself too seriously like
never going to come up with this whole
skies and then you guys we're not to
vote is our future
hmm well I mean we're only what two
months away from potentially having
Trump's outside hey there's a lot of
shit that I thought could a greater time
but I still can't see that happening you
know at all I just can't see people
agreeing to that or at the very least
when this movie came out there was
nothing else just like you know yes
America it could happen it gonna green
oh I could see plenty of people who
would agree to it just like I don't have
to get like a vote or anything like that
again TR UMP you know but it's like even
even the Pearl living in here where like
that happened so it's hard for me to say
oh no I could never see people voting
against their best inches of course um
it but it's more that the entire economy
would collapse in a heartbeat that the
entire nation wouldn't just completely
correct you do that once because it
makes no sense just all violence you
know doesn't come from we're just angry
it really does not come from that you
know I mean there was no insight to what
I know why me of course it can often
does with you but if there's no insight
to they're just too happy sophistic
there's just no insight into like why
people do crimes and violence and stuff
like that means our people do it because
they have to it's not just I'm just
pissed you know that's not the reason
the whole commentary was weird because
it's like it's a rich white family that
holds themselves up but then gets
attacked by another rich entitled white
preppy looking kid and I ended I don't
know what the hell the movie was trying
to say but it felt like it was trying to
have some sort of socio-political
commentary and I'm like I even know what
the hell it was no it just totally
doesn't work and it makes no sense but
that's the price if I can't believe in
the premise like that one idea was kind
of cool like I'm just like no that would
be an interesting idea like if you get
one kill and you can legally get away
with it hmm because that's different
from the that's different from the purge
yeah but the whole concept
purge I'm like in one night the entire
country would just fall apart like and
if it would if it had done this more is
a dark comedy yeah we've gotten away
like if this was like fucking demolition
man I'll read this mediocracy or
something like yeah Renee this really
funny although even that's seeming more
real to life and helping face than the
verge um but even the theocracy I could
buy more like I said me we are kind of
in a way seeing that more nowadays but I
could buy that more the purge just there
is nothing to it that would like satisfy
the mass majority and also work ring
like this piece and have everybody okay
and stuff and the whole idea of the
movies trying to prove it doesn't work
and it's like no shit huh they're lying
the project was I will give the sequel's
this much credit apparently they like
start to like rip apart the flaws
they'll go okay I saw the second why did
when I saw the second one the second one
is almost a good movie because it takes
I swear to god the director same
director and writer I listened to all
the criticism of the first film set
that's a good point and it is this
horrible shit I wrote this sequel that
actually like kind of shows like yet it
wasn't working and like it's actually
kind of a conspiracy by the government
and stuff to like get rid of poor people
and stuff like that it's like this is so
much better it is like much better
commentary it goes out it is a city it
is own world it's doing work like you
couldn't hit it doesn't quite work you
would have you would literally have to
have every nation involved do it because
of America did that I can't imagine what
would happen to the global economy yeah
let's give one person look at what
happened brexit now imagine in the
United States just decides to do it yeah
like imagine that so it still wouldn't
work but at least he's truck but the
second film cuz I saw in the second film
thinking well maybe we have to review
that too because you know it follow up
but it's like I mean it doesn't quite
work but it's like it's really close I
really gave them credit that they were
trying to fix the problems of the first
one and they really do fix like the
majority of them and
very hard to make it make sense it
doesn't quite work but it's like really
really close like and it was actually a
lot more entertaining and the characters
more interesting and it showed all the
various other things you can do with it
not just home alone you know it's a
reverse where the kids are trying to get
after the adults um so I really really
gave credit to that sequel I didn't see
the third one um box earlier I actually
that was the one that by the trailer I
probably just wanted to see the most cuz
I'm much okay that looks fucking
hilarious
what no no I don't I don't know I don't
know if the movie is good or not I
actually didn't even read the reviews
because I might wanna catch it on video
sometime I didn't realize it came out
honestly did I thought it wasn't that a
summer movie no no I I think I just I
sort forgot I know that was the only one
like when I saw the trailer I was
laughing my ass off I'm like that the
crowd I saw it was laughing too um but
again I don't know it's like are they
going balls to the wall like this can
really happen like in the first film are
they like kind of retconning and making
it a little clever I'm like maybe it'll
kind of come full circle and everything
will make sense of that I don't know I'm
really curious I was hoping it would be
the army of Darkness to be Evil Dead
first one super serious second one's
pretty funny that third one's like a
just fucking um but uh but yeah and I
think they're so cuz the film was a big
kid I think it's an idea almost like a
the 70s like so are those extreme
futures those are yeah it's a notice
yeah dystopian like and not that we
don't have those dystopian you know
movies right now then we'll do a young
adult books but there's something where
this just seemed like such a basic
chaotic idea you know Cal like Hunger
Games just like get children together
they kill each other and you know but
it's well blended but is well I did one
wheel each other and it's somehow like
saves the world like it's a good thing
that would be like what it would make it
drove me nuts about I'll be honest well
Hunger Games the only thing that drove
me nuts about it was I didn't like the
world building in that I'm just like
this makes no fucking sense I'm like
even in a post-apocalyptic future it's
like the idea that they would keep
sending kids I'm like no like none of
this really is making any sense to me
um that I give a shit for this battle
royale or whatever I'm like whatever but
yeah even than that I'm like Ethan
making these is always a better story
yeah
and the purge was the the purchase had
nothing to it well in The Hunger Games
Hannah I know it's a weird comparison
but Hunger Games did have interesting
characters they had interesting world
even though like I said there's a lot
stuff that doesn't make sense about it
but you know it's intriguing and what's
gonna happen next with this one it's
just home alone you know that really is
it except it's serious it's serious home
alone and it's all like this could
happen
Hunger Games I don't think there's ever
a fear they never emphasize America
we're going this route I never think it
like it's like okis home alone crossed
with panic room and some second-rate
slasher movie like that's what the purge
is it's like if yes like if Hunger Games
was happening but we were watching it
all from the rich side and they were
just really trying to emphasize like to
everyone including the people at home
you know it works it really works it
really works and then like wait it
doesn't yeah so there is just this
pretentious december's like a the
counters I'd except for Henry
well yes our fake Henry um yeah I he was
the only one I like because he hasn't
fun is only one like Willy Wonka that
way like Gene Wilder is the only kind of
likeable character and yeah they're just
rooting for him to kill ha ha it's the
same it's the same idea like it's like I
like those kids are enjoyably you know
despicable and jerky and stuff like
nobody and this is you know enjoyable or
unique or anything like that they're
just kind of how would it been actually
that would have been hilarious in there
like the kids can't dad wouldn't would
it be great if Henry was in that groove
was it like Willy Wonka's groove it
itches I know boom you see mr. Wonka I'm
getting that everlasting gas stop just
let us purge we gave you a chance to
give us that Gobstopper and you did not
yes yeah cause I got a feeling thing is
a flashbacks how much funny I guess the
only thing that bothers me about the
movie it wasn't even the movie it's the
movie just to me would have come and
gone I wouldn't give it a shit
it's the way to head this following of
people that were just like now this is
important this means something yeah
that's what bothered me about that I'm
like no this is garbage guys like enjoy
it if you want but this is gone we could
really go and like I said the second one
if it if it were goofier I actually
would have went a lot more like if it
even acknowledged it is like death race
2000 the alleged oh fuck yeah well
pretty much more fun with this mom hell
yeah
um but it but what it it almost reminds
me of um like did you hate this movie
more than I do but I know what you're
saying about what you're talking about
district 9 it reminds you that kind of
thing it's just like it's so pretentious
about them like you should have just
gone as a dark comedy
yeah well district I tried to but it
wasn't funny and it wasn't good
commentary wasn't it dark i kim i watch
it's totally everything is trying to be
like the office it's yeah you like arts
or always like i in action film it's
trying to be you know dark commentary
trying to be serious trying to be funny
and it just feels out all of them
looking sucks different feel ugh sorry I
know I love you able love it but it
sucks
I feel like this movies kind of in that
boat of what you yeah it's just it's
that so pretentious no we can see you
can't
this movie will allow you to see oh
pretty inches how many people just
hounding us like with messages about
like in comments but like just don't get
it what district I'm definitely no I'm
just talking with this one I got a bunch
like you don't get it it's commentary no
there's the sense that justice has his
commentary doesn't mean it and Terry
yeah the the the problem like that I
wonder if this was a problem like when
we were kids with film goers that would
been our age now with our parents like
30 years old like of course they didn't
have the internet back then but it was
idea that like you could throw out any
like stupid commentary but you don't get
it it's common oh I definitely was
younger I I ate up all that stuff you
know I definitely did um but I did see
out good commentary yeah I didn't get
angry if someone else didn't like it or
something especially if I heard why and
stuff but I mean there
like this you know well what the hell is
that movement I loved a lot of younger
and then like a week later I'm like this
actually sucks waking life remember like
we saw that this was this animated like
mind blowing thing whereas calm like was
waking like it's easily forgettable it's
like nothing but like a bunch of
different it's just people sitting
around talking philosophy and it's
animated
oh oh oh fucking move yeah like that
could be really abstract really
interesting what you can do with
animation and they okay now I really do
anything with it really it's just
people's not about philosophy and when I
was younger I ate it up because I didn't
like see anything like that I loved
philosophy I loved animation but a week
later I was just like yeah what what
does that mean what that could have been
what that real movie went in one ear out
the other which is what this movie does
if it wasn't for not Henry yeah okay
the only thing whenever I think about
that film I only think of him I don't
even do you know what I didn't remember
what the family fucking look like this
is like I can't remember that's it I
said I'll even remember those Ethan
Hawke okay I forgot I can't even rule
like that is how disposable those
characters were um one helmet fit at the
very end there's the twist that the
neighbors actually want to kill yeah
totally didn't see that coming how much
more fun again would it have been if you
just see the neighbors next door they're
trying to get in and it's just like
these sweet little ladies are
middle-aged ladies and stuff and you
know this guy wears a gardeners and
they're just trying to get in and where
the math I got the makeup and they just
turned total psycho that is so much fun
I'm sure that was some sort of
competitive its commentary just because
in real life you're more likely be
killed by people you know it just works
and that total strangers so that was a
clever commentary to show you how in
reality they were afraid of the wrong
people now of course they weren't gonna
get killed by total strangers like in
the beginning of it so that means
commentaries sort of mother but it's
clever it were it just works
um yeah I think that's the idea behind
the movies that they're trying to show
it would work but at what cost no it
wouldn't work and the costs are
incredibly obvious that no one would
ever do it um I would fight you I would
find a more fascinating tale is if they
did it escape from New York style where
you set up some like libertarian utopia
that you know a quarter of the country
is always wanted and you just take like
three states chain them together build a
giant fence around to be like okay no
laws there go do whatever you want what
you can't watch you do Galilei yeah
don't you go in you can't leave but that
that would be an interesting like and
that may come be about that and see what
what happens yeah I feel like there's a
good idea here and there's good
commentary there that they just haven't
tapped into and chose not to dive into
they just are left at this very basic
idea you know it's produced by Michael
bass you can see like he's like no no
just emphasize the bad evil this could
happen you know stuff like this by
Michael Bay's it's like let's have a
hint of a brain but make sure you
bludgeoned it with everything else yeah
you know it's like this is the guys try
and make Transformers movie serious see
you know and like anything's the really
high drama you play the big I pick music
when they're on and the choir come on
don't is prime you know and it's like
not Eddie's good dancing oh boy um and
he's just trying to do the same thing
with the purging no he didn't direct it
um but so yeah so like I said I really
give credit that the second film does
try to really wreak on it I do like you
bring out the second phone because I
really give kudos that it did that
because there's a lot of films that come
out and they suck is moving but their
hits and then like the sequel just does
the same thing as hey or it just worked
uh but yeah but with the sequel the
director legitimately tried to make it
better and like I said I really salute
you for doing that I just think that's
really really cool that he tried he saw
it he noticed it and he tried to fix it
um I have no idea if he did the third
one I don't know if it maybe the third
one does come full circle made the third
one some - I'm ready on this everything
so I and I
I don't want a kind of why I love the
time to election year especially this
election that I'm sure we bred does the
midnight screenings I gotta ask what he
thought of it yeah
but I suppose I could just look it up
okay cuz I saw the other two I might as
well just see it I might as well watch
it but yeah it was um
is movie set the only entertaining part
is the concept for how seer say they
take it and and knock Henry those really
are the only two really enjoyable things
about it um so yeah trendafil on Henry
portrait of a Nazi um so yeah I think
there's anything else about this film to
say uh I I feel like it's all kind of in
the review and even though now do you go
back to Livy like how do you live in the
same fucking neighborhood with people
who tried to kill you night before like
some way they just the purge work so
well they just accept it I didn't what
does it oh shit doesn't work doesn't
work no it doesn't fuck does it look
just a badge of those neighbors had
failed like why I mean they do fail
imagine had they live like you're gonna
sit there and like get the mail and
water your plants then that stays
staring at Graham across the street
looked on come on what why you're my
favorite too is that you knows no I
forgot about the ending cuz like the
neighbors can either get killed and then
like you know um what's her name Queen
Lannister comes in max mad says no
nobody else is gonna die here so they
just have them all sit there quietly
it's like a minute before the purge ends
and then like one of the women is like
yeah tries to grab a gun and she smashes
her head and says we want yes and it's
like were they really so desperate to
kill these people that like one minute
died you know and it's like it's really
obviously not worth it um so yeah this
movie is so dumb uh this is one of those
very therapeutic films to talk about
like just oh it feels good to finally
talk about this cuz like not everybody
loved it wasn't a critical hit and a lot
of people that's alright yeah that's
pretty dumb or didn't make sense or
whatever
but like yeah the ones that were just so
sucked into it just like you know the
commentary and it's it just felt so good
to rip into it um so yes it's a very
therap I like it pretty funny and or
unintentionally funny part yeah so and
of course just Matthews brilliant
yes hello iceplug that that bit he
didn't worry smacked himself into the
wall and then is like yeah oh yeah it
all fine of course looking at the brain
cameo at the end just all of that it's a
really funny review oh that's right that
was bad that was a little with the
recent Martian rap also at the end um
you beelined and like track them down in
the cation I've never seen I held him at
gunpoint I'm in my own purge he was like
walking straight a nose and it was
amazing um so uh yeah that's about it
all we can say is the purge works no it
doesn't but toss it know what does it
know what does it know what does it